Kristof can I borrow your wagon and then
I'm not very comfortable with the idea
of that you are not going alone
[Music]
[Music]
promise me we do this together okay
we're so happy for you Elsa you finally
got the answers you were searching for
and now you can be who you were always
meant to be but we have to admit we were
convinced that Anna would run right
through you when you came galloping down
the ocean on your water horse because
well you looked stunning in a ghostly
kind of way all jokes aside we know that
Anna and Kristoff will take good care of
arendelle it's what they were born to do
I should get her a ring
we loved the ending of frozen - but
we're curious about what exactly
happened to Elsa sure she thought out
and saved arendelle in the nick of time
but did she really come back to life or
is she living as a spirit keep watching
to find out which major clue dropped by
Anna confirms that Elsa is in fact an
elemental spirit and not a human
we have always feared Elsa's powers were
too much for this world
now we must pray they are enough hearing
a voice that no one else hears is
usually a clear indication that
something is wrong but for Elsa it's
just another day in the life Elsa has
been a little Moody ever since her
coronation day clearly she had bigger
plans and becoming Queen she sings about
wanting to go into the unknown in frozen
- and chooses to awaken the spirits
despite the mini risk all Elsa ever
wanted was to feel complete to feel like
she belonged and she knew that the voice
calling out to her could give her the
answer she needed to be happy so Elsa
jumped headfirst into the unknown Anna
know I have my powers to protect me
you don't early on in the movie we find
out that Elsa loves a challenge she
takes on the wind spirit right off the
bat and eventually gets Gale to submit
to her will she does the same with the
fire spirit who turns out to be a little
salamander named Rooney he doesn't take
her long to win him over either and
lastly also manages to tame the knock a
wild water horse else abuses her ice
powers to outshine these three elements
leaving the earth giants to be tamed by
Anna but most amazingly Elsa finds out
that her powers were a gift and not a
curse where did you learn math
but before Elsa could celebrate the news
she had to mourn her parents passing
once again after all she did find out
that their ship capsized while they were
out searching for the origins of her
powers after reaching the frozen islands
Elsa sings the beautiful ballad show
yourself as she closes in on the voice
that's been calling to her it's then
that Elsa realizes that she's been
searching for herself all along as Elsa
gets closer to the answers she so
desperately seeks she starts to
transform her hair goes wider than ever
before her skin a little more
translucent and her usual blue dress
turns as a bright as a fresh sheet of
snow and soon we find out that even the
ice cream can freeze solid but before
that happens
Elsa finds out what caused the north
alder tribe and the arendelle soldiers
to attack as it turned out AG nars
father built the dam to trick the people
of the forest his peace offering was a
sham and he attacked an unarmed man
angering the spirits but to find out the
truth
Elsa plunges deeper into the memories
where it's so cold she eventually
freezes Elsa thaws out once anna brings
down the dam but there's something
different about her she's more spirit
than human Elsa finds out that she's the
fifth element which is why she's always
felt misplaced
she's the bridge between the magical and
non magical worlds and she belongs in
the enchanted forests with the other
elements Elsa came so close to the
source of her power that she fused with
it becoming who she was always meant to
be
many of us were convinced that Anna
would pass straight through Elsa when
she ran to hug her which she didn't but
since the other spirits have a physical
form
it doesn't debunk the theory on a points
out that their mother had two daughters
and that there are two sides to every
bridge and fans are inclined to think
that this statement was yet another clue
that Elsa was now a spirit honest and on
the side of the living as the newly
appointed queen of arendelle
and Elsa stands on the side of the
spirits finally restoring the balance
between both worlds
so while Elsa might appear to be living
and breathing her existence goes beyond
that hey you subscribe to the things and
turn on those post notifications if you
want to be the first to watch our latest
frozen 2 videos go on YouTube settings
and turn on notifications if you're
watching on your mobile and that's a
wrap on the secret twist at the end
frozen - do you think Elsa has
transformed into an elemental spirit or
do you think she came back to life just
like Anna did in the first frozen film
sound off in the comments before you go
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up thanks for watching we'll see
you soon